alright guys time one minute late I
think haha alright
so Jacobs there Laura Tyson good to see
all of you guys alright so can everybody
hear me if there's a problem please tell
me are we good
should be yeah all right
thanks Jacob all right here we go so
let's start with the website so do I
have anything to talk about it's not any
questions I don't think so not that not
not this months not this month all right
Adam appears all right Adam I'll the
usual the usual suspects are here so
that's great all right so I'm gonna
start with the the website and then
we'll move on to the other platform so
so David david Flores asks can you talk
about your new technique of setting
stones into your carvings I'm curious as
to how you managed to attach them to the
carving itself and how do you decide
what stone colors to use in any given
piece so those of you who have seen it
or not if you follow me on social media
the the I mean I've been I started this
technique a while ago I guess about
maybe three years ago I did my first
carving where I inserted semi-precious
stones and and then I've been kind of
looking for different Commission's to be
able to do this because because I just
think it's an interesting technique it's
an interesting the the great thing about
that technique is is it it really shows
how can I say there's the the possible
vibe like the vibrancy of a tradition
because when you look at those images
that I did with the inserted stones they
look like something which which has
existed in the past but it hasn't
there's never been that type of Mick
of carving with inserted semi-precious
stones you know especially and with
gilding and everything I've never seen
that in in churches before so so it's
interesting it's interesting for me to
make something which when you look at it
you feel like it could have been made a
thousand years ago but at the same time
I couldn't have been made a thousand
years ago because they weren't using
that technique so the way that I attach
them is is pretty labor-intensive we dig
the hole I mean we carve a hole into the
stone and so the stone is set into a
stone piece is set into the the main
stone that's the carvings in um and then
with just with epoxy because epoxy with
stone it's great it holds you know
forever and so with a with epoxy we glue
the stones into those into those let's
say crevasses and if if there's a little
bit of too much like there's too much
play between the stone and the rest that
the the semi-precious stone and the rest
of the stone then with some grout or
sometimes with a mix of stone powder and
glue and an epoxy will fill in the the
holes to make it nicer so so you again
you're gonna see some like the one I'm
doing for Jordan Peterson I'm so I'm
working on it right now
with my assistant he's actually doing
right now putting in the the stones
there's a dragon at the bottom of that
carving and it has all these these these
pieces of lapis lazuli in the dragon
like at that on the the scales of the
dragon are all lapis so it's gonna be
it's gonna be pretty intense and so
we're doing that right now
I think I posted some pictures of that
as I'm working on it and so I mean how
do you decide the the stone colors you
use mean it it's just like any any
composition you know you have to balance
you have to pick the right colors just
like you would in a painting so there's
no you know we we look at the different
colors and and some colors have some
let's say some kind of symbolic meaning
gold and I mean obviously some colors
have more symbolic meanings but some are
more just for it to be her
Onias all right so Luke Fleischman asks
three questions the dreaded question
first question is what are your thoughts
on the yang gang meme that I posted
something on Twitter about that where at
first when I saw this appearing I was
seriously confused I'm like what is this
thing like what is this for I'd never
heard of this guy and then I was
wondering why all the all the you could
say all the Qian type you know all the
reddit chan type memes were we're all of
a sudden you know bubbling up for this
guy and you could we could see there was
a like a a weird pepe dragon figure and
all these different memes and so I know
guys I don't know what to think about it
I think I've seen I've seen some people
talk about it and suggest that it that
it this might be a move from some some
like left-wing people to try to to get
some of the Trump vote to like get the
people that voted for Trump and to and
to kind of get them on board to vote for
this this Yank fellow but I don't know I
have no idea I mean I don't I don't
really follow very carefully and so some
of the things that have come out have
been funny someone mentioned that you
know Andrew Andrew comes from Andros who
comes from the the the root for man and
and yang obviously is the is the Chinese
principle for masculinity and so so
people thought that it was like this
return of the of the masculine I don't
know you know I I don't I don't know I
don't follow American politics close
enough but for sure it's very strange it
seems I mean it might just be a I you
know I saw some means where it was it
was like you could see people was it
like there was Bernie Bros and
and Trump supporters kind of coming
together around this yang guy and so and
so maybe that's the move that people are
trying to do because a lot of people
have noticed that that the the new right
are the alt-right or whatever you want
to call it not all of them but some of
them they're not they're authoritarian
they're not libertarian and so you know
they have maybe have more they're not
necessarily anti state and so they're
they're actually pro state and pro state
control and so they might have some
things in common with with with the
extreme left and so it's not good it
wouldn't be really great if those two
forces came together if the extreme
right and the extreme left came together
that's not good that would not be good
because that's what happened in that's
what happened in via Germany everybody
forgets that the Nazi means National
Socialist it's it's a it's a joining of
of the right and the left together into
one thing and so I don't know I I hope
that it doesn't it doesn't work whatever
plan they have okay so could you go into
the symbolism of a demigod would I be
wrong in thinking of it as a sort of
precursor to Christ well I would say
precursor to Christ in the sense that
everything is a precursor to Christ to
that extent you could see in some of the
stories of the demigods you do find some
things which tend to point to Christ I
totally agree but I think that it's
important to understand in the story of
Christ and in the tradition after after
Christ it was extremely important for
people to for the the fathers to say
that Christ was fully God and fully man
and the reason why was to avoid the
problem of the demigod in part part of
the part of the demigod because you
could see some recent resemblances right
in the notion that God the Father you
know that that the mother of God became
with with God you know with this with
the logos and so would that story
resemble you know the the kind of
raptures that you see of the of God of
the you know Zeus or the or that God the
Father God of Greek or Roman mythology
who impregnates women and so I think
that the fathers really tried to
separate themselves from that although I
I don't think that it's completely
insane to think that in some ways it's
pointing towards Christ I think it's
also important to understand the
difference one of the big differences is
that the is that the demigods are more
akin to the to them to the margin
they're more akin to the periphery
because they're a myth they're they're a
hybrid and they're kind of viewed as
hybrids and that's why they appear as
kind of you know as these heroic figures
who heroic not necessarily in the sense
that we understand it today but in the
sense that they they're strong you know
they like like Hercules or or Achilles
you know that they have superpowers type
thing and so they they they're there to
to fight off to to add to they fight off
monsters they they do that kind of stuff
because they're in a way they're they're
actually on the on the border between
humans and gods that they're not totally
gods and they're not totally human and
so they're they're kind of these
monstrous figures so I think that it's
important it's important to understand
the difference so all right so third
question from Lou good questions by the
way Luke this third question is what do
you think the symbolic significance of
global global warming climate change
might be well I've been wanting to make
a video about that I was thinking of
making a video about a video about that
at some point because I think that the
the global warming climate change thing
it what it is it's a form of secular
apocalypticism you know it really is the
same structure as when I was
young evangelical and people were
telling me that you know the world is
gonna end and this is the sign that and
there's doomsday in front of us and it
is a form of millennialism you know it's
a form of the end is nigh it's the same
thing it's it it's it's just closed
differently but you know it's the same
as the nuclear holocaust when we were
when we were kids and you know the we we
thought that the world could end with a
nuclear holocaust it's all the same
thing it's all the same thing and I
think that I think that it's interesting
to study the the the global warming
climate change thing I think that using
this glue whether or not it's actually
going to happen I mean whether or not
it's just a political narrative or or
whether or not it's a mix of political
narrative and and science I I really
actually do like one time someone asked
Jordan about this and I thought his
answer was pretty wise he said I can't
differentiate the science from the
politics when I hear people talk about
climate change and so because of that
it's difficult to know when people are
actually being objective in terms of
science or whether they're there in a
narrative and I think it's it's really
great because it's showing us you know I
did a few this last video about how Flat
Earth is is showing us how the world the
world of kind of rational thinking is
yeah let's say of this rational bubble
that we created in the Enlightenment how
it's breaking apart and and symbolic
thinking is coming back and so it's
coming back in all kinds of weird ways
at first it's not necessarily coherent
but this idea that we can no longer
differentiate the narrative from the
from the the quote unquote science is a
is partly us understanding that you know
that meaning is inevitable and and you
can see it as a frustrate it's
frustrating because we see it in because
it's happening as the world is kind of
falling apart we see it in news we see
it we can't we listen to watch news now
you can't ask yourself what's their
narrative you can't
we can no longer just wonder whether or
not they're just telling you the facts
because it just seems impossible to do
that anymore and so and so in terms of
in terms of global warming I think that
it's a it can be a useful tool to
explain to someone what it means for God
to judge the world because the way that
people understand and say when they read
the story of Noah they read the sort of
know and they think how could God be so
horrible how could God destroy the whole
world and cause a flood and and it's
really fascinating because if you if you
study the the the traditions of Enoch
you see that as the the world becomes
more and more technological as they
learn about magic and about smithing and
and and everything technological and as
they do that become they become more
worrying
they war they have more fights between
each other and they also become decadent
and they create mixture they they also
you know become sexually decadent and so
it's like all that is happening and then
the flood and so you think oh how
horrible is it that God would would
punish the world that way but the same
person that would think that would can
still can also think that if we continue
to at the pace that we're going if we
continue capitalism continues the way it
does you know if we continue to pollute
the earth like this we're going to the
world is going to destroy us and they
sometimes it really does have like a
mythological narrative where it's like
mother earth is going to spit us out and
and the world is going to reject us
where as if we're parasites on on the
earth and so and so it's actually an
interesting way to show people what the
judgment of God is because God's
judgment is is is also the causality of
our own actions it's like the judgment
of God is related to the it's the
meaning how you could say this way the
judgment of God is often the meaning of
the consequences of our actions right
and so it's like someone starts to cheat
on his wife and
and then you know his wife his wife
finds out and his wife leaves them and
then he starts to drink then he becomes
an alcoholic and then and then he you
know he becomes a he loses his job and
he becomes a total loser and then he
gets on heroin and then he you know he
starts to and then you you'd say like oh
that man that man has been judged by God
you know he's under the judgment of God
but the judgment of God is the meaning
of the consequences of his own actions
and so and so I mean not that sometimes
it can be like a like a lightning bolt
that comes down I believe that is
totally possible but but but in general
usually there's a there's a relationship
between the actions that you pose and
the judgment you receive that's why if
you if you look at medieval
representations of Hell for example the
the punishment that the person receives
in Hell is always related to the sin
that they that they committed and so for
example someone who was a glutton you'll
see them in Hell being stuffed by demons
you know like being stuffed with food by
demons until their stomach explodes you
know and so and so and so the same thing
like with with with let's say someone
who had a kind of sexual perversion then
you'll see them being abused by demons
in hell and so it's always if the idea
is that your actions bring about their
own consequences and those consequences
are also the the are also God's judgment
upon you so I hope that answer is that
all right all right so Joe's ur 733 2
questions could you comment on the
symbolism could you Laura Jill says yes
do a video on the seven deadly sins for
Lent have you a good idea to do it to do
a video on the on the on the traditional
like traditional deadly sense maybe I'll
do that I know if I'll do it for Lent
but I maybe do it at some point okay so
two questions could you comment on the
symbolism of adapt of adaption so the
symbolism of adaption well
I don't know I don't know if you mean in
general I mean if you mean in general
it's not very difficult to to understand
the the symbolism of adaption is the
capacity for the pattern - it's what
shows that the pattern transcends the
particular particulars and so as as
let's say that the ground changes as the
situation that you that you're in
modifies itself then you adapt then you
will adapt things to that change and so
the the the the change which happens in
the circumstances it's like a question
it's like saying you know I don't know
you're you're you're you're moving
toward you want to - you want to walk to
the end of the street to put your I
don't put an envelope in the mailbox
and so you're going there and then as
you you you you're walking I don't know
a tree fell down and is blocking the
road and so now you have to adapt
yourself and so based on the goal based
on the purpose then you have to change
in order to reach your purpose but the
pattern the basic pattern or the basic
logos is is the same and then you adapt
that's what you change based on your
your purpose so that is that is the
symbolism of adaption adaptation but
you'll notice that I think that a lot of
kind of evolutionary theorists will not
agree with me because they don't believe
in an essence so they don't believe in
logos they don't believe in a Telos
although you could say that reproduction
is already at a lows like that the
desire to perpetuate the desire to
remain relevant - to remain alive that
desire is already a a purpose and so in
that sense it's what makes you be able
to then adapt to whatever circumstances
present itself to you but of course
people who people who
talk about evolution don't believe in
intention in the in evolution they don't
believe that it's only randomness and
then but there is still even if there's
randomness it's it's really interesting
it's like even if there's randomness
survival is a form of of choosing
survival is a form of purpose and so
it's like we you know the let's say you
you won't want to use the word God but
you could say you could say that no
matter what there's some principle which
selects what will survive and then that
which survives there's some principle
which there's some principle which makes
that or self reproduction or whatever
makes that the the Telos of life so I
don't know hopefully that answered
enough on on adaptation and so so I read
Lewis's discarded image and JR tokens on
fairies but I'm still a bit unclear as
to what they were understood as could
you comment on fairies as well I mean
the way the way that I understand the
way that I understand fairies is that
they're they're they're they're kind of
these wild principalities they're
they're Rhema there okay you can see
them this way one way you could see them
is you could see them as remainders of a
past hierarchy that's an interesting way
to see things like fairies to understand
that let's say there was before a long
time ago before Christianity there was a
basic that's a there was a hierarchy of
of principalities and then and then
Christ came and the Christianity came
and replaced that hierarchy probably you
would think that probably because it was
decadent probably because it was already
breaking apart for whatever reason in
terms of Celtic religion that's for sure
the Romans had dealt a blow to Celtic
religion way before Christians appeared
on the scene you know
Caesar slaughtered the druids because he
wanted to control the Celts by the time
the Christians arrived the the the Celts
their religion was in shambles
and so you can imagine that so their
religion is in shambles
there's no struck you know there's this
chaotic fringe let's say principalities
which are still kind of floating around
and that would would create a form of
kind of tribalism and different little
little little tribes that that are in
competition with each other that can't
kind of unite you know and then I mean
probably under the Roman Empire that
helped it to create some stability in
some place at least so then when
Christianity replaces that that
hierarchy there's still a remainder of
the ancient hierarchy and that remainder
ends up getting pushed out into the
margins and so they really become like
wild spirits and that's why the images
of these of the fairies and whatnot is
that they're usually associated with
kind of forest you know out in the out
in out in the forest out in kind of dark
places and and kind of out-of-the-way
places you could say and so and so I
think that that's what that's what they
are and so that's the way that I that I
understand fairies but it doesn't mean
that they're all that they necessarily
have to be negative you know they're
just wild and I think that's probably
one of the things that some people would
disagree with me on is that is is that
you know how can I say this it's like
they're still little they're still could
be little nuggets of of something that
you can find that is worthwhile but it's
very random and it's very difficult to
tune to to discriminate you know and
that's why I like you know you you you
know you meet for example let's say you
meet like New Age people and these New
Age people they kind of went into their
weird New Age world and
then they started to have these strange
experiences where they're encountering
all these spirits or whatever all these
things all these weather depending on
what they how they see it they're
encountering aliens or the encountering
spirits or they're encountering fairies
that whatever how is it is that they
want to to to formulate it but they're
they've kind of thrown themselves into
this chaotic sea of of intelligences or
principalities and then and then it's
usually to their detriment like it
usually is to their their slow down fall
into a weird kind of self-absorption or
you know all kinds of strange things but
once in a while like I know people who
who in that world that kind of weird
new-age world they had an experience
which which brought them to Christ you
know they saw the mother of God or they
they they they encountered something
which some some being some some
principality who who pointed them
towards towards Christ and so it's like
I don't know you know it's it's not
totally impossible but uh I hope you
guys understand what I'm talking about I
usually don't use these types of these
types of words but the thing that
happens it is once you start to
understand that the world manifest
itself as intelligences and manifests
itself as as Logie and as and as purpose
and and even to a certain extent as
persons then you'll notice that that
that these things start to make sense
and you can you know like we all saw
this we all saw the the Alex Jones on
Joe Rogan I think anybody's here would
probably have seen that and when Alex
Jones is talking about the you know the
the clockwork elves and and the you know
the that they're aliens that they're
clockwork elves that they're all these
different things that that people
encounter when they they're taking uh
you know their
in DMT or some other kind of psychedelic
drug you know and and also you know we
talked about this idea that when when a
group of people take psychedelics they
they can have the same experience they
can encounter the same beings out there
and so it's like that's once you start
to understand that that that that's how
the world lays itself out as
principalities and that those
principalities are like little
personalities they're just like Oh your
personality is like is a is a cohesive
you know it's a cohesive set of patterns
that that make you something that make
you a person and and those cohesive
patterns they have a certain form of
existence you can see it in a fictional
in a fictional character as well how you
can under you could recognize Batman by
a certain to pattern and so you can you
know it those principalities they have a
they exist and and it's possible and and
for people people encounter them it's
probably not a good idea to to to start
to to do that I don't know I don't you
know I've never taken psychedelic so I
don't know but um I think that he could
I think that it could lead people astray
just because unless you really have a
very high level of discrimination and a
kind of a really high level of training
you know you meet all these wild
patterns and you you can attach yourself
to them and they they can totally leave
you into weird health weird directions
but alright so hopefully that hopefully
that makes sense you guys and I'm not
freaking anybody out probably I'm
freaking people out but okay okay so
Laura Hills says the symbolic world view
is definitely allowing you to unpack
many things Jonathan however I'd like to
know how dangerous someone like Alex
Jones is someone who both perceives at
some level the symbolic structures of
things but because his worldview is
fundamentally unsound he can lead people
astray
seriously astray he's
obviously not grounded in classic
Orthodox small ohhere Christianity he's
connecting into archetype symbols but
doesn't have the full picture so I think
that you know I think Laura that
question you asked is great I think I
think it really fits into what I was
just talking about before is that that
it is it is possible to have these
intuitions you know and to for example
go into you know kind of enter into this
intermediary world of principalities you
could say and have a perception of them
and having an intuition about them and
and it is a dangerous thing if you're it
can be it can be dangerous and it like
you said it can totally lead people
astray the problem we have today the
problem we have today guys and I think
this is something that maybe I should
mention more and more is that there's
not a lot of there's not a lot left
which is not contaminated
you know everybody everything is tainted
and everything is tainted and everything
is very strained right now the whole
world is very strange everything is
weird and everything is upside-down and
everything is kind of strange in we're
in that we're in the margins right now
and so and so it becomes difficult you
know like if you look at what happened
now like if you look at the scandal that
happened the Catholic Church the book
that came out what is it just last month
I haven't read the book but I've kind of
heard a lot of people talking about it
and you know the insane amount of of
kind of disturbed you know gay orgies
and and pedophilia and whatever that
that is in the higher levels of the the
Vatican of Rome and the Orthodox Church
is not completely free of that we had
some scandals with the the the head of
the church in Serbia you know there's
even some videos of him with like
children and stuff and so it's like
there's some weird stuff happening in
the places where the hierarchy is
opposed to in our own hierarchies let's
say in our own hierarchies of people and
so when things get really really weird
you have to really you have to keep your
eyes open is all I'm saying you have to
keep your eyes open and I think that I
think that someone like Alex Jones is
someone that it's worth paying attention
to
to a certain extent not too much but to
a certain extent because he's he's
acting he's acting like a kind of tuning
fork where he does intuitively
understand a lot of things that are
going on intuitively and he also is
acting like a canary in a coal mine
because he has become the one to attract
the ire of the powers-that-be and so
because of that I think it's important
to continue to to pay attention to him
as a character let's say as a figure in
this story and I think that's going to
be the same with Jordan Peterson we're
gonna I think there's some questions
about him in the question I'll talk
about that when I get there but it's the
same thing it's the same thing that's
going on with him as well alright okay
so I think let's see I think those are
all the questions from the yeah I think
those are all the questions from the
website all right let's go to subscribe
star alright not a lot of question
alright okay so Christian Chad Christian
chat that is he is Christian chat here
and the the is that that is no way
that's a real name I keep every time
I've come doing people and I see I see a
name and I go that's not your real name
and then it turns out it is if Christian
Chad is your real name
that like you are a living meme if
that's true but I I don't know if that I
don't that's true so Christians had said
you've said in multiple videos that we
have not learned the correct lessons
from world war ii what lessons should we
have learned and why did we arrive at
the position we are today hmm so the the
questions that were being posed in world
war ii there I mean there was a lot of
things going on it's hard to totally
totally focus on just one but I would
say that in at the basics you could
really see that it's a it's playing out
the problem of of having eliminated a
proper ontological hierarchy it's it's
it is the result of the it is the result
of the the breakdown of the medieval
synthesis we call it and so in the
Middle Ages there were there there came
to be a synthesis between you know in
that very very dark time that everybody
likes to talk about in the dark and the
dark ages
but you know in the in the let's say
from the 10th of the 12th centuries
things started to stabilize and also in
the Byzantine Empire the intellectual
tradition there there there really was
the synthesis between let's say
Hellenistic thinking even even some
elements of Persian thinking and then
the the Judaic thinking in the figure of
Christ so there's this this this
synthesis of a massive scale and then
that's hard to break down in the in at
the end of the Middle Ages and and the
world war ii is the last is the fruits
of that and so this is a place where I
totally do agree with with Jordan
Peterson in terms of the two extremes
you could call them there's more than
two in in World War two there's more
than two really and so what we see is a
kind of internationalism a kind of
classless in theory right you know a
classist
worship of the of the of the worker work
worship of the lower part of the of the
the hierarchy and and wanting to make
everything everything equal and
everything universal without identities
without nation without all that so this
kind of their this clay was really a
globalism in the form of communism
versus extreme nationalism and exclus
exclusionary let's say nationalism and
so that that's what was going on and we
don't underst
the causes like we don't we don't we
never talked about how never talked
about how Nazism is is a reaction to
communism in a large part you know how
communism is a reaction to capitalism
and then so you have this weird these
three we're three oh that are kind of
fighting for the twentieth century and
we rarely we rarely talk about that
because now we have the same problem we
we have the same problem where we have
nationalism and in globalism and and
it's like and then we have the the let's
say a ditch effort to preserve a kind of
Society of freedom or whatever but that
Society of freedom it's it's what you
would expect from a society of freedom
it's it's degenerating its falling apart
it's it's breaking into it's breaking
apart because there's nothing to hold it
together and so you know we we can try
to scratch hold on to it as much as we
want you know it's not gonna hold
because it doesn't have it doesn't have
something bringing it together and so
then come in you have this then you have
the the the globalist answer and then
you have this nationalist answer and it
and both of them are going to lead us on
the same path as as what was there in in
the in you know in the 30s all we need
is an economic
mass economic downturn that's all we
need right now it's like everything is
on edge and if there's a there's a
massive recession it's like there's no
hole it's no hope yeah so sorry guys I
hate when these become dark I don't like
I don't like the dark
I want the dark stuff all right so
Kristen Chad asked I see a progressive
authority that thinks of itself as a
resistance movement but acts like an
established order this is all very
confusing symbolically can you unpack
this for me yeah it's it really is a it
really is an upside-down world we live
in an upside-down world we live in a
world where where we live in a world
where the victim acts like a tyrant you
know and so that was it was also the
same we saw the same thing happened in
in World War two again though the to the
to the Nazis and the Communists both
portrayed themselves as victims and then
acted as tyrants and so it's confusing
but it's it's not it's not that
confusing because it has to do with
pride it has to do with the the first
sin it has to do with it has to do with
viewing yourself as a as innocent
viewing yourself as a victim and then
because of that being blind to your own
sins and being blind to your own actions
on on on on the others until you can
imagine you could imagine Satan you know
not accepting God's judgment thinking
that he was right and that that his you
know his casting out of paradise is a is
a is unfair and is unjust and that he
deserves better and so because of that
he thinks that he deserves to be God and
so he whatever he does he doesn't
there's no
there's no he can't see his own sins he
only sees the sin of another you know
and it's not it's like yeah I so it has
to do with it has to do with pride you
know I pride is the dark side of the
ascent you know it's the I always talk
about how they're - they're every
symbolism has kind of two sides you
could say and so pride is the the dark
side of the ascent you see that in I
gave a talk on st. gregory of nyssa and
i talked about the ascent of the
mountain and thence and st. gregory of
nyssa in the book of moses he hints - as
he's talking about the ascent of moses
he also hands to the what he calls the
false ascent or the you know them the
ascent which is really a descent yeah
and that's the ascent of pride and and
that's it that's the tyranny that's all
that stuff is all related to - to not to
seeing yourself as a you know as a
victim of others and and that's there
for your your actions shouldn't cannot
be judged by by anybody because you're a
victim so you know and it's that's how
genocides happen like that's that that's
that's very scary the the fact that the
fact that the left right now continues
to portray itself as as a victim all the
while being in power in terms of
institutions that is accept is so scary
that is that is what leads to that's
what leads to - that's what leads to
very bad places in society you know the
the the same thing happened with the
Tutsi the Tutsi Massacre the peoples
often don't know a lot about the Hutu
Tutsi that's a dynamic the the TWiT sees
those that were that were massacred
where were a minority and were the
leaders of the country so because they
were the minority and the leaders they
they you know they they
cap thing for them thousand and the who
choose were the disenfranchised and so
the who jus saw themselves a
disenfranchised most europeans before
the people don't talk about this but
most Europeans especially the left-wing
Europeans most left-wing Europeans that
were in Africa at the time of the
massacre before the massacre began were
all pro who chew because the Hutus were
seen as the victims of the Tutsis who
were in power and then when the Hutu who
started to Massacre the Tutsis they they
felt like they had every right to do
that because they were the majority
because because they had been distant
they were the victims of the Tutsis and
therefore whatever they did was
justified so you know yeah
okay so John B asks he asked come on
this Jordan Peterson thing is getting
weird can he keep doing this without
Christ so I guess he comes to the
question he comes to the whole thing
even the the question about with Alex
Jones is that we're in I'm wearing a
messed up time guys and and that's one
of the reasons why I'm very careful not
to not to just say things like oh you
know there's been a lot of criticism
Joanne Peterson with with Vox today's
book and with Milo turning against some
even Rachel Fulton Brown turned against
them on Benjamin a lot of the more right
leaning people have turned on him and to
me I don't see the world that way you
know I have said positive things about
Milo but there are plenty of negative
things that I could say about Milo and I
have said some negative things as well
there are positive things that I can say
about Durham Peterson and and I have of
course I have maybe more appreciation
for him
because we we've become friends but
there's a lot of negative things about
him as well he says a lot of wacky stuff
especially in terms of Christianity and
so I don't I I don't feel like I've ever
encouraged Christians to follow Jordan
Peterson but I think that he has
important things to say and when he says
those I'm happy to hear him when Milo
says important things I'm happy to hear
him when you know when Ben Shapiro says
important things I'm happy to hear them
when whoever it is I'm I'll just say
that's that what they said there that's
good
same thing I like Alex Jones I don't
follow Alex Jones I don't I don't I
think that he's he's a Caesar he's he
has strange ideas and he's hyperbolic
and you know but I think that there's
some things that we need to pay
attention to what he in what he's saying
and I can point you to those things and
the rest we can we can ignore and and
and not and not and not focus on because
and the reason why I think that's the
best way to be right now is just because
like I said we're living in a time where
everything is upside out everything's
topsy-turvy we need to keep our eyes
open because things change things are
changing very fast in there and are very
very weird you know and I would say
don't take anything that anybody is
saying you know automatically it's just
not it's it's not the time except for
those that have halos you can you know
those that have halos and you can read
so wait
Christian Chad is as appeared and he
said that that is his name this is
that's amazing your name is Christian
Chad you are a living me my friend that
is pretty awesome dad gelareh it's sad
so funny so so so so who's that who's
that who's the Virgin who's the Virgin
like side to your Christian chat we have
to figure out a meme here with with you
all right that's awesome
I think you just totally made my day
guys that's great
right so we're done with the we're done
with the with the subscribe star
question so let's go to patreon The
Verge yeah that maybe that's what it is
Jakub Russell says who's the Virgin God
list we have to all right okay so here
we go we've got a to here so okay so
Frank Rowley asks after listening to sam
harris and joe rogan expressed their
desire for a road to forgiveness and
redemption regarding those who have
transgressed on social media or in the
public square I was struck by the sense
that it might not even be possible in
the secular context what are your
thoughts yeah I I totally agree I
totally agree and I think that I think
that that's the surprise one of the
surprises that people are facing right
now one of the surprises people are
facing is realizing that the world that
we've created this secular world you
know and all these causalities and
nobody planned out has brought it to a
point where there's no forgiveness there
just isn't and so when when you say when
they say we need to create a road to
redemption the problem is who's going to
arbiter your redemption who's going to
arbiter your forgiveness there there's
no there's no structure there there's no
road there there's no there just isn't a
way for it to happen it can still happen
on a personal level you know obviously
it's it could still happen on a one rent
you know one chance thing but as as as
structure we have we have crazily
removed it and it's it's all sides you
know it's a it's both sides what is it
that I saw today was it today where I
saw people talking about bata O'Rourke
and and saying that you know bringing
out the fact that he wrote some some
like murder fantasy
when he was 15 years old 15 years old
and they're bringing this out into the
public sphere as if this somehow has any
bearing on his his life it is absolutely
insane what's next people are gonna
start to say hey we learned that you
used to watch horror movies when you
were 15 so you enjoyed watching people
be decapitated and you know getting
their getting their heads chopped off
and getting disemboweled Wow that's
pretty weird you are a disturbed person
I'm wondering who would vote for you and
it's like my goodness it's it's very
scary it's not not it's not good it's
not gonna get better it's not gonna get
better all right
so drew met Jacob Jacob says oh I'd be
in serious trouble it's funny because
Jacob and I we had a private
conversation today we talked on skype
and we actually talked about that that
about horror movies and our young days
all right so drew mcmahon asks i was
discussing with a friend who is
christian the relationship between truth
and love and which is of higher rank I
claimed love and he claimed truth
arguing that love is an emotion that can
fool you or be manipulated to a degree
but that truth was binary binary and
clear-cut sort of a mathematics versus
language juxtaposition and therefore
supreme what are your thoughts it's even
fair to try and is it even fair to try
and put these into a hierarchy it's
funny because that conversation is one
of the very first conversation that I
had with Jordan Peterson because I
remember we had met the for the very
first time we had met at some event that
he gave about men I forget what it was
and it was like a debate he had about
men and then we're gonna go to the
restaurant together but he wanted to
walk it so we're walking no we were
walking back to his house after the
restaurant we're kind of walking and
then we started talking about this this
and
he was saying that he thought truth was
at the top of the hierarchy and I was
saying that it's love and and so I can
lay it out for you why I think that it's
love I think that it's love just like
same Saint Paul says right the the
highest of these is love is is because
we need to understand love as the very
manner by which things exist right the
very manner by which the question and
the answer can can exist the very manner
by which an identity can encounter a
something that's not their identity and
then coexist right love is the
possibility for multiplicity and unity
to to to to coexist that's the to me
that's the highest definition of love
it's it's we are one together without
you without multiplicity going away it's
like one and the many at the same time
that's what love is and so to me that is
the prerequisite for for truth to even
be concept for even to be anything and
love is in a way beyond being in in the
strict sense that we understand it in
the sense that it's the it is right it's
the manner by which being can even lay
itself out because for being to to be
there has to there has to be identity
and not identity or identity and
multiplicity for for you be able to even
see anything praying for anything to to
exist until yeah for sure I'm with st.
Paul on that I think the highest of
these is love alright so
gnorm gold a asks you had a conversation
with jordan peterson a while back in
which you spoke about intersectionality
and how christ transcends categories
existing in all of them at once which
could which would seem quite paradoxical
this idea strikes me as similar to a JK
Chesterton wrote in orthodoxy quote
mysticism keeps men sane he has always
had one foot in earth and the other in
Fairyland
he has always left himself free to doubt
his gods but unlike the agnostic of
today free also to believe in them
he has always cared more for truth than
for this for consistency if he saw to
truth that seemed to contradict each
other he would take the two truths and a
contradiction along with them his
spiritual sight is stereo stereoscopic
like his physical sight he sees two
different pictures at once and yet sees
all the better for that unquote okay so
my question aside from looking for you
to discuss the idea of this paradox more
fully is the this paradox too much for
people to bear so they need to simplify
it and thus we get the fragmentation of
Christianity across religious lines as
well as fundamentalist and atheists who
just put blinders on that paradox in
order to make sense of Christ
thus succumbing to low resolution
thinking all right well hmm for sure I
think I think that the the paradox is
important the idea I'm gonna I'm gonna
make some videos I already made a video
about about this it's one of my first
videos I think it's probably the first
video I put up
it's called sacred symbol sacred art and
in that I talk about the left and the
right hand
I haven't made any more videos about the
left and the right hand but I wrote a
whole series of articles on that on the
Orthodox art journal and I'm probably
gonna make some videos on that on
because I think it's relevant also to
what we're seeing the whole left brain
right brain notion let's say of of
wide wide perception and precise or you
know let's say category making or
category maintaining and exploratory you
know exploratory behavior so I think
that I think that that you really do
need those two those two sides and I
think that as you said Christ transcends
those two sides that's why we that's why
Christ is the one who's judging Christ
is the judge who has the sheep on his
right hand and the goats on his left
hand so so Christ yeah transcend that
also unites them together just like you
in a way in a very small way you also
unite those two sides within yourself
you could say Christ does that at a
cosmic level and so you do need those
two sides to kind of to function
together now whether that has to do with
the fragmentation of Christianity maybe
maybe it does have to do with that in
the sense that the tradition the
fullness of the tradition should to a
certain extent contain both sides right
should contain when you could call the
legal side or the solid side and then
contain the the prophetic side you could
call it and so in the old testament you
had the you had the Levites who were the
actual structure of the of the the the
worship you know who who did the rituals
who you know who who did sacrifices all
that and then who also let's say
transcribed kept the torah kept the laws
you know had all the laws and everything
and then you had the prophets who were
you know read ezekiel like crazy stuff
where you know they're being pulled by
their hair and into heaven in there and
they're you know they're seeing all
these these things and they're going
around telling people you know to repent
and all that stuff and in the christian
christianity we we have the the
ecclesial structure and then we have the
saints
and the aesthetics as well and so the
those two sides the the the kind of
coexist and although for example we
recognize the authority of your priest
or your bishop or whatever the Torah the
authority of the Saints is higher right
it's higher than the authority of your
of your priest but you do have to submit
to the authority of the actual church
but there is a another aspect which is
there to kind of balance it and so I
think that that's that's why the
fullness of tradition needs those two
sides needs you know the ascetic in his
cave who is in in a trance
you know contemplating the mysteries of
God and you also need the fudgy priest
who you know who tells you that you know
you who lays down the law once in a
while and tells you you should do things
this way and he doesn't totally
understand why and it's very frustrating
because sometimes you feel you're
smarter than him but he's still a priest
and so it's like okay so that's life you
know and and and and you know I totally
I mean this maybe as an opportunity to
talk about that because one of the
problems that I'm seeing is people a lot
of the problems I'm seeing right now his
people who have kind of through through
through their research a little bit
through my videos maybe through other
people that they've encountered online
they are attracted to to Christianity
they're attracted to the church and then
they go to church and then they
encounter that side right they encounter
that kind of dogmatic very kind of
strict legal doesn't seem to totally
understand the deeper aspects of things
side and then they get disillusioned and
they think what is this you know what am
I doing here and everything and and and
I think I really encourage people to
understand that that's a necessary part
of the of the thing and and to be able
to take to take things in stride and
understand what people's functions are
people have different functions you know
we couldn't have only
a bunch of free thinkers who are who are
trying to understand symbolism that
wouldn't work it's not gonna it's not
gonna hold the world together we also
need people who who are who are telling
you know we're saying okay so this is
what we're gonna do this is one we're
gonna meet this time this is how we're
gonna do things you know we're gonna
whatever structure of authority is there
so we need both um all right so Adam
Adam she lard asks are there any other
figures like Saint Christopher Bishop
Baron talked about the donkey Jesus rode
a Jesus rode as a Christopher okay no so
Bishop Baron talked about the donkey
Jesus rode as a Christopher or Christ
carrier bear of Christ to the world
thoughts and then he says seems like
Mary would be another example of a Saint
Christopher and John the Baptist am I
losing it and then a laughing face yes
it's not the same it's not to say so
well you know it's not total it's not
it's not totally it's not totally
completely separate right so the the
donkey that carries Christ mr. Baron is
very smart to notice that that is
definitely that is definitely a
Christopher and very much so
all right one of the images of Christ
that the Church Fathers saw in the Old
Testament was the bar lambs ass if you
guys know the story bar ylim was varlam
was a was a sorcerer who was going to
curse the people of Israel was going to
curse the chosen people and as he was
going to curse the chosen people the an
art an angel appeared on the road with a
sword you know to to I don't remember if
in the story it says he has a sword but
then angel appeared and was going to cut
him down and and then his ass starts to
move to the side veer to the side and
and Balam is like
beating it so that it gets back onto the
path and then it starts to veer again to
the side and he's like beating it to get
it to the path you know and then at some
point the ass lays down and Bala Bala is
like beating is his donkey like what are
you doing why aren't you moving and
everything and then the duck he speaks
and tells him you know that he saved his
life and that he saved him from the
judgement of this angel and so that has
always been an image that deal that the
Church Fathers used for Christ and it
saying so really is this notion the
possibility of the animal aspect to
carry the logos and so that ass is an
extension of your body right just like
you ride your body you know you can also
extend that into a car or a horse or an
or a donkey or whatever like you you
know you you extend your power to direct
yourself with these and so the ass
becomes an image of an image of that and
especially an image of that because the
donkey is an impure animal as well and
so there's also this really this idea of
the foreigner in the notion of the ass
as well just like Christopher was a
Canaanite just like Christopher was a
was a foreigner the the ass is also
related to the the foreigner it would be
difficult to go into all the reasons why
but one of the reasons is that he's
impure another reason is some of the
character in the Old Testament like ham
or who is a different characters who
were foreigners and who are like the the
red the red donkey um kind of helping
you understand this notion of the of the
foreigner as there and and he were Jews
until today they interpret the the
donkey as the four nations you know and
so you have this sense that when Christ
is riding the donkey he's riding the
foreign nations so you can imagine for
example the Roman Empire converting
that's like st. Christopher
transformation where st. Christopher
converts to - - to Christianity carries
further out where in terms of the mother
of God it's different it's similar in
the sense that in a way the mother of
God represents this potentiality that
receives the logos but they're due there
there's really a difference between the
wild like the animal foreigner
prostitute should do the other hand left
hand warrior like that the foreigner
prostitute donkey impure all that stuff
and then the pure the notion of
potentiality has this pure untouched
virgin state in which the logos finds
the proper house so you really have to
separate those two because they do they
do end up being important in in the West
that's why you really do have this you
have to marry that I've married the
mother of God and then you have Mary
Magdalene and so those two opposites
represent two aspects of of the church
and two aspects of the Incarnation in
the in the East we don't have Mary
Magdalene in the way she's in the West
but we have Saint Mary of Egypt so Mary
of Egypt is everything she's a she's a
prostitute she's a foreigner she's lives
on the other side of the Jordan she has
all the elements about that wild aspect
which is then can also receive Christ
and be tamed by by Christ and so we have
to be able to be able to really
differentiate the the two one you could
call it the inner mystery of the pure
heart which receives the logos which
descends into it and manifests itself
and the other is the garments of skin
you could say that can be transformed
into garments of glory something like
that hopefully that makes sense guys all
right and yeah and here here actually
you know he says John the Baptist and I
think that that's an important that's an
important aspect because the mother of
God that's why in the icon of the of the
of the Babli in the Oh in orthodoxy we
have Christ in the center sitting on a
throne and then to his right is the
mother of God too
his left is in John the Baptist and so
the mother of God is the right hand
she's everything the right hand is she's
pure she's untouched she's she also is
this condensation of the the logos into
her room she has all that in her and
then Saint John the Baptist is the left
side he is wild he wears his garments of
skin lives in the desert he you know he
screams at the authorities you know he's
a he's baptizing people he's he's
killing them like he's keep putting them
in water and he's bringing them out he's
a you know and then he lives by the
sword and he and lies Christ said live
by the sword die by the sword you get
this head chopped off and so and and
then you have the same anyways you have
these right hand and these left hand
Saints the st. Peter and st. Paul also
have that same structure and so and so
that it's interested this relates more
to the other question I was asked in
terms of in terms of the two sides you
could say all right
so David Patterson asks Jonathan picking
up a question I read in January I would
be interested in to hear you compare and
contrast the stories of Noah and the
shipwreck of st. Paul I would also be
interested to hear your views on the
recent movie Noah sighing Russell Crowe
perhaps this would make a great video in
the future
well I actually wrote an article on the
Noah movie it's probably the only movie
criticism that I've actually written out
and so if you go to my website you could
probably find it it's you go to the it
was written on the Orthodox our journal
so you could probably find my
interpretation there in terms of
understanding the relationship between
the shipwreck and Noah I would say but I
think that that story of the shipwreck
of st. Paul is for sure extremely
interesting and I think it's really
worth looking especially at the part
where the boat crashes on on on Malta
and then it really is the shipwreck part
of the story because
it has its strings together all these
elements about that have to do with
let's say a voyage out to sea or a
voyage towards the the the foreigner you
could say or the crossing over of the
sea you know like Saint Christopher
could have been carrying st. Paul across
the sea to go to Rome and in the
meanwhile in the middle he has to deal
with the craziness of the of the border
craziness of the periphery and so you
know that first of all the ship wrecks
the the you know the structure in which
they're in is it they know they don't
they get stuck for the winter right if I
remember correctly they or is it I
forget now I think the boats know the
boats do wreck anyway one interesting
part is that it says in the text that I
should have the text in front of me it's
like here am I trying to remember
everything it says that their barbarous
people which is already interesting
because here he they're facing these
these barbarians these he's these
barbarian foreigners and then there's a
crazy part where they make a fire and
then st. Paul gets bitten by a snake
right st. Paul gets bitten by a snake
and they all think is gonna die but he's
not gonna die so it's like he goes to
the to the end to the edge of the of the
world and then he encounters these
barbarian foreigners he has a shipwreck
they also I think they run out of food
as well right
they eat the meat but then they throw
out the grain which is really
interesting which has to do with with
throwing up the seed but then eating the
flesh and so it's like they eat meat but
they throw out the grain and then they
go on this this like island in the
middle of nowhere and they meet these
barbarians and then he gets bitten by
snake but he ends up being fine and so
you really have this so it really is
this crazy move into the periphery like
right into the into the into the into
the beast he could say as he's going
towards Rome now people don't don't
don't like this they don't they don't
like the fact that that uh that all of
this is is is prophetic
what's going to happen you know which is
that st. Paul crossing from from Israel
to Rome that's it that's the story of
Christianity people that's what happened
you know it's like the the barber the
the the on the there was a crossing over
and the Romans are the ones who became
the Christopher Romans are the ones who
carried Christ and the Romans converted
you know in Christ everybody was waiting
for a messiah that was supposed to -
let's say to take over the - to take
over the Roman Empire and that's what
happened it just took 300 years but
that's what happened and so that story
of st. Paul crossing over from Israel to
Rome and then getting you know going
through this kind of almost like Ulysses
you know all these ulysses very short
but a lot of ulysses experiences meeting
barbarians getting bitten by snake you
know tossing out the seed keeping the
flesh it's like all that is all is it's
a great little little little segment of
the Bible and then moving to Rome - to
become a martyr but then then to become
the new seed of this new world which is
preparing itself - to appear on the
horizon so so yeah it's great story
probably the dancers so Adam says that
he linked the Noah article in the
Facebook group thanks thanks Adam
all right so Tyson and Jessica Gabe Gabe
I hope you're pronouncing that right I
think you're here the Gabe or Gabe Gabe
hopefully this will tie in with Adam
shall ours question earlier in your
research on st. Christopher have you run
across a Greco Egyptian god her man
abyss if so what are your thoughts on
their on their relationship to one
another I can't help but see
similarities both in their appearance as
dog-headed men and as guides or bears
across liminal spaces threshold rivers
and so I'm gonna give you guys a massive
spoiler because it's good it's a very
sport of the long term because you we
talked about the donkey's and we talked
about her man you missed and
both those appear in our epic graphic
novel that we are preparing and so you
will see both of those and you will see
the relationship between Christopher and
these and these elements in the in the
story so look forward to that it's a
little bit okay Tyson says rhymes with
tribes so Tyson trice in Tison guide
okay all right I will remember that um
so yes there is a relationship now there
is no it's really interesting because
this is an example where there is
absolutely no historical relationship
between the fact that Christopher is
represented with the dog with a dog head
and figures like an abyss are her man
abyss there is no there's no historical
causality between the two but obviously
there's a pattern relationship because
like you said in your question both of
them are liminal both of them cross over
a river you know because an abyss was
the the character that crossed people
over the river in terms of in terms of
the in terms of death in the Egyptian
mythology and so and so there's
definitely there's definitely a
relationship in terms of the pattern and
and I think that yeah it's definitely
worth pondering about that there are
other there are other characters like
that someone sent me a story I forget
the name of the I think it's Orion
there's a story about Orion also
carrying a boy on his shoulders across
an expanse of water so so Orion is a
giant right he's a Titan and so you get
I told you guys that Christopher is
either a dog and a man or a giant and so
it's like those these stories they keep
repeating themselves um and there's also
the story about the hybrid when them
Hercules is going to cross a river with
his wife and he can't cross and so
there's a center who comes and proposes
to cross his wife over the river
and and then you see the negative aspect
of the crossing over because the scent
or tries to to to to take his wife or -
rape - rape
Hercules his wife and then Hercules has
to that's like shoot an arrow and kill
the scent or in order to to stop him and
so you can get the negative aspect of
the of the crossing something over into
in that story all right all right so
let's see another question by Tyson and
Jessica guide what are your thoughts on
the agency of holy relics and mere
screaming icons they seem to act in the
world on their own accord and with
intent are they by doulas powers
conduits non-human persons none of the
above so the way that the way that you
you have to see the power of relics or
the power of icons they have to be seen
as extensions of the the saint who is an
extension of Christ's Kingdom in the
world that's how you have to see it you
have to see it as like there's a kingdom
of heaven which is manifesting itself
and that Kingdom is a hierarchy of
persons who are in Christ and so the
Saints are in that hierarchy they've the
Saints participate in the in the they be
they have become one you could say they
they rule with Christ there's a way to
see it so they become patrons they
become holy patrons of of things in the
world and that also includes you know
that's why they also have a patronage in
terms of people they have patronage in
terms of buildings like churches were
named after different saints who are who
see the saint as their patron now none
of this removes the kingdom of Christ
that's really important and it's very
difficult for people to for especially
people coming from Protestantism to to
understand you know when you receive
from your parents you are still
receiving it from God it does the fact
that you receive you the bread from a
lower principality doesn't necessarily
mean that it's not also coming from
above right it's like the the the person
who's giving food out to the homeless in
a shelter the food isn't coming from
that person yes it's coming from that
person for certain extent because
they're the ones who with their the love
in their heart they're giving you the
food but the food is coming from from
the organization which is which is
organizing this event giving food to the
to the to the homeless and so the person
giving out the food you can say thank
you to that person and you could be
grateful for that person because they
are because they are there participating
in the process to bring you this gift
but it doesn't it's not it's not an
obstacle to understanding that the food
is coming from higher above so that's
the same thing with Saints with relics
all of that and so you have to see a
relic or a miraculous icon as as an
extension of of the of the saint so it's
harder for people to see it in terms of
those types of causalities because
because of weak because we're
materialist but think about it this way
you read a book by someone and then your
life changes because you read that book
that you're healed of some some thing
that you had that you were dealing with
some some issue some problem like you
your life changes because you read a
book and so that book is an extension of
the person who wrote it but it's also
not just an extension of that person if
that book is having an effect on you a
positive effect a good effect then it's
also an extension of a prince of a
principality if it's having a negative
effect it's probably an extension of a
negative
principality of a wild principality or
you know some I I hate I don't like
using I should sometimes use the word
demon but I don't wanna use the word
demon because it people have weird ideas
about people have to they have a horror
movie ideas about that and so it's hard
it's hard to it's hard to use those
words without without people not
understanding what you're talking about
but if let's say the book is is helping
you then that person necessarily has to
be a vehicle for a patterns that are
beneficial to you the patterns that
exists above him that are higher than
that person patterns of behavior
patterns of being patterns of thought
patterns of of how the world lays itself
out and so if it's helping you then it's
all of that is is together and so when
it when it when it's related to
knowledge and demeaning and and to cycle
psychology some reason we understand it
but it's harder for us to understand
that someone could encounter let's say a
relic and be healed of something because
they come into contact with that relic
which is which is an extension of the
saint who is in under the the let's say
who's in the kingdom of heaven in the
kingdom of god and is ruling with christ
the the world hope that makes sense you
guys but I think that's that's how you
have to see it you have to see
everything as fitting up you know I
don't know how many times I've talked
about the hierarchy since since since
I've been talking to you guys but that's
the way that that's the that's the way
to see it that's the way to kind of
understand it alright so I don't know if
any of you guys have some questions in
the in the chat so I was gonna finish at
10:30 but we do have a few minutes left
if you guys if you guys want to so once
again
I'm pretty sure that this QA I'm not
gonna put make public pretty sure that
I'm not gonna do that with this one
every time is like I realized I I get
the feeling that I'm saying things that
people won't understand because I know I
know that you guys that have been
following me for a while for a long time
I hope I really hope that I've taken you
far like I I feel like I did start with
like baby steps like trying to say okay
these words that we use you know they
mean something they're not just
arbitrary let's understand what they
mean and then I'm bringing you to a
point where I can say something talk
about elves and and I can talk about
elves and fairies and and and all this
stuff and hopefully you know I'm not
freaking any of you out and you
understand and you can relate it back to
the things that I talked about before if
not go back and listen to my old videos
because because you know yeah all right
let's see we've got a question here in
the chat so norman called a asks with
cry i'm saying your name in French I
don't know if you're French but it seems
to me like it would be gone day with
Christ defying categorization embodying
paradox is this an example of Christ as
a supreme individual that we should seek
to follow this example of not being able
to put to be put into categories okay so
okay so there there's a difference
there's a difference between
transcendence or synthesis and confusion
and it's really important to not mix
those two up because there's literally
the opposite and they're literally
they're literally one is an inversion of
the other and one is like one will lead
you into two serious problems and so
there's that there's a type of there's a
type of not fitting into categories
which is a form of hybridity a form of
confusion a form of mixture a form of of
strangeness all of that is a manner in
which
we don't fall into categories okay now
Christ Christ in a certain manner does
defy category in the sense that he joins
them together so he joins everything
together so he's he is he's the king and
he's the the you know he's the the
stranger he's the king and he's the one
he's the criminal who's crucified
outside the city but because he's
innocent then he also doesn't compromise
the fact that he's the king so he takes
these two extremes and he joins them
together into one person you know but
there's no confusion so the way the way
that that the father's always express it
is always unity without confusion and so
Christ is man and God fully completely
without confusion and so it's not that
he doesn't fit into categories like a
monster doesn't fit into categories it's
alright and that's really super
important because the world is so messed
up today that you will see people talk
about let's say the fact that being a
weird androgynous type of person is
somehow in the image of Christ in the
sense that Christ transcended the the
opposites of of gender it's like it's
true that Christ transcended the
opposites of gender but he did that by
being a man he did that by also
embodying a particular and so his
transcendence happens through a
particular and it's nonetheless a
transcendence but it's not a kind of
weird Universal because that's what you
know like the the globalist idea is
really that it's like let's eliminate
difference let's eliminate in particular
and then we'll find this transcendent
thing but that's not how Christianity
works Christianity is through the
particular and so it's like you are a
man a woman uh you know you're a
Canadian and American you
you have this history you have this
family you have this culture you have
all of that and so it's like through
that you can reach something which
transcends it but not as a kind of
strange abstraction you could say of
your particular so hope that makes sense
all right so Adam asked we do consider
doing another video on Gregory of
nYSSA's life of Moses I mean maybe I
really I made two there's two videos
there's one that's called there's one
that's called finding God in stories and
then the other one is called what's it
called
something about st. Gregory needs a
think of things about st. Gregory of
nYSSA's like for Moses and so I don't
know I don't feel like I said what I
wanted to say I mean maybe if you guys
have some questions about saying ten
grab your nieces life of Moses we could
you can ask them and and I'd be happy to
answer them I think that if I'd sorry
yeah I think that if I do make some some
videos on other subjects related to the
Church Fathers I'm hoping to make
something more about maybe about st.
Maximus I'm going oh by the way you guys
know I'm I'm doing I'm doing I'm gonna
be in Seattle in May you can find that
information on my website and
participating in a conference with
father Stephen Freeman and one of the
subjects is going to be the the
Anthropology of hesychasm so I'm going
to talk more about Orthodox mysticism
and it's relate and how the structure
that the fathers gave to the human
person is adjacent is parallel to the
this cosmic structure that I'm always
talking to you guys about now the garden
and the tree and all that and the temple
and the church and so I'm going to show
how the the the human person is
represented in the same manner hopefully
that'll be more patristic it's like it's
hard to be - it's hard to go into things
that are too precise directly on the on
the youtube channel just because
you know the audience is so wide what I
when I think I'm gonna do if I make
videos like that it'll be like if I'm
invited by a parish to come speak then
I'll feel totally comfortable talking
about specific things very specific and
then I'll put it on the channel but it
everybody will see that it's I'm in a
church I can talking in a church and so
to me that I've tried to find a balance
between those types of videos and the
more general videos so that people don't
get lost in what I'm saying so yeah so I
said a lot of crazy things today but I
really had a lot of fun I really enjoyed
it I'm starting to really enjoy these
these q nays and as usual guys I want to
thank everybody for for your support for
being part of this little strange group
of people trying to understand the world
through this lens I'm excited about
what's what's coming next you know I I
feel like I'm in a groove now I feel
like I found my team in terms of working
with working with people to edit the
videos and to for the podcast and the
website and and all this is kind of set
and I have an assistant for the carving
and so I feel like I'm in a pretty good
group so I'm I'm able to make more
content and so I'm hoping to to keep
that up and tried to have at least one
video a week maybe more and yeah and I
think I might try to do a I might try to
do a livestream once I never done it but
like a like a public livestream just to
see what happens to see how that goes if
anybody shows up so I might try that at
some point and and alright guys so I am
going to sign off and I will see you all
around on Facebook on YouTube and I'll
see you next month alright